[Music]
divinity original sin - I almost said
divinity - again don't say that yep
yeah divinity original sin - from Larian
Studios over in Belgium Belgium the
Belgian studio from Belgium also one of
the writers on the teams Kevin Ben Ward
formerly before Pete Brown was reviewed
they're here at game spot for how many
years not 12 I don't know it was a long
time so he worked on it but John Luke
you and I have been playing it Rob
you've been kind of watching over our
shoulders because of all the weird [ __ ]
we're doing in that game just you're
just wearing a boy I really like that
game yes so I played a little bit of the
first one I liked it a lot but I never
got into it because it was so dense this
one's even even more friends but somehow
it's not overwhelming me yet because
I've put maybe eight hours into it and
I'm still in the first area I know
Dave's you and over over in our UK
office spent like 16 hours and that was
a cool character that looked so sick
that lizard it's very cool but it makes
the game a little harder because you
have to cover up your face or most
people who will run from you so that's
yes it was so funny he's weren't like
what you know like looking over her
shoulder like why are you wearing a
bucket and he was like so he's in the
menu inventory which is like full HUD
just like we've a Gleeson oh there's a
little bit less of it Apache so you can
kind of see this kid he was talking to
Mike goes to like remove the bucket kid
immediately just starts running just
like imagine that in real life like why
don't you saying so you could play co-op
in this game which is amazing because
already it is dense as hell Jeep has
held the emergent situation that come
out of like that figuring out how you
can combine attacks and elemental stuff
but also just how you can combine
characters in your party like sometimes
you'll go up to this one character that
this this lizard companion that you have
has beef with and then he'll go up and
talk to him be like yeah yeah go talk to
him I'll catch up with him later and the
hill his attitude towards you will
increase because if their attitude
decreases too much toward you they'll
just leave the party forever I have not
seen that but that can happen and the
lizard hates me somebody yes please go
talk to him I don't want to lose you
you're my best fighter but also then a
different character will go up and talk
to that same character I got I'll talk
to him too and all of a sudden she'll
just she'll be like and it's like it's
like text from the narrator be like she
promptly put a needle
stomach and ripped it made him stare at
his own guts on the narrator probably
good here's a great example of call this
is me playing co-op with Ben Gingka and
my brother and this is one of the party
members you can get and I basically like
was talking to him and saying like hey I
really want to get you as party member
we basically sealed the deal all of a
sudden the dialog box just booted me out
and Ben had like just taken a shell you
can pick up objects and just throw them
and he threw a shell at the dude and
then all of a sudden the guys like you
have dishonored me and then he just some
guy like him and he basically were just
like so he won't join our party anymore
we have to murder him now should we
reload should we like start over and we
were thinking about words like you know
no we're gonna we're gonna stick with
this and we're just gonna kill this guy
yeah this game is uh me like debating
like I have a save we can load just f5
at any time it'll save it really fast
there's there's something has to be said
about like just hearing that like as
funny as it sounds like when you think
of like a like a classic like squad or
buddy Trek adventure movie like there's
always that one shady character he's
always screwing up everything it's it's
a heist thing it's like yeah he's weird
he's a loose cannon you can accidentally
just piss off anyone and murder anyone
like completely 180 right like yeah Oh
Mike you had said another really funny
thing well sorry speaking of Michael
Madsen and mr. blonde being that that
lion it's so totally yeah he's just
gonna cut someone's ear off what was I
talking about
you were playing and you go ah whoops I
just accidentally killed her apparently
apparently you were like addressing
someone a woman who had like her throat
well she was bleeding out from this
story point that I won't spoil and and I
was I was pressing a cloth to her neck
and trying to save her and Chris who
works here walked over behind us and we
were talking about it and I was kind of
listening to your conversation like a
work-related one but also playing and
some I honestly think my finger just
spazzed out and I click through to
dialogue options instead
one and the next one was aligned with my
mouse and it just said slit her throat
but like you said jean-luc it's one of
those games where I'd like the best part
of this game is just rolling with your
choices kind of like echo it's all
coming back now but it's like I was like
I could load to save but I also kind of
liked the idea that my character
literally just accidentally killed her
right you might not be in character but
I'm also kind of like well we'll figure
out who my character is as I go you
could argue that you mercy killed her
she was already bleeding and that was
the option said it said you decide to
finish her quick and give her like
solace or something I was like I
probably could have saved her if I
really put my mind to it otherwise known
as you're a dick and you just killed her
no question so I didn't play the first
one and a little intimidated to jump in
can I just play it do I have to know
anything about no no no not at all
yeah you can just jump it yeah you can
just jump right in can I jump in yeah
you can play a few reviews are saying
this is like one of the best like
isometric very like a traditional PC
RPGs in a long time if I'm like um
people always reference Baldur's Gate 2
as one of those like gray ones and we
get a lot of those recently yeah
no was it a plane scape torment that was
way more you're right for sure I played
that and that hat was way more all
mostly based on like text and the combat
was few and far between this game you
can just fight with anybody at any time
not that you need combat for a good game
like this but that kind of feeds into
your character and stuff but this game
the the combat is really rad because it
like plays into this like experimental
like kind of like elements combo stuff
so you get you know there's basic stuff
like okay I'm gonna lay down oil and
then I'm gonna shoot it with a fire
arrow and it's gonna spread fire
everywhere but then you get like weird
stuff where it's like okay I just killed
that
in a pool of blood it's now like spilled
on the ground and I can Electrify it now
there's electric blood that alike zap
anyone also undead characters if you try
to use a regular healing potion it will
hurt you'll hurt them and a lot of food
does too and I still have not figured
out which food because sometimes food
heals me sometimes it's probably I was
gonna say ro no no I just picked up an
apple I don't recipe and then I picked
up cheese in it I hope I pray you have
more stories of this like I'm trying to
like pretend about to die let me get
this we love cheese Russian Roulette
pull the trigger Mike or it's like
you're like just like some question
we're it's like come in my house like
young man like take off the bucket no
okay just putting stuffing it is an
honour in this household that you have
you dis bread it's either take off the
bucket or eat this dark meat man no but
but also poison heals on dead characters
right have to use poison so one of the
characters she is an elf I believe with
a scar on her cheek she an elf yeah she
she has this ability she could just
throw these poisoned flasks so someone
or she maybe she had one equipped but
she came up next to me in a fight like
you see a bunch of characters grouped up
here and two I have two undead
characters because my main character is
undead but you also get another
companion and we were really low in
health so I had her throw the poison
like bomb essentially at us so it killed
the person next to us but gave us ran
right yeah it was awesome you're like I
need healing and she just like throws
like a dagger in your back yeah ideal
this situation was actually kind of cool
so I picked them one of the origin
characters so you have um you can make
your own custom character but you can
also pick an origin character which has
like its own specific backstory that
actually can then like play into the
into the narrative and my character's
backstory
because I heard like that's if you want
like that's maybe a good way to start
it's just kind of like pick an origin
character because you get that extra
narrative my character has like a voice
inside their head that
like possesses them and tells them the
do stuff like a demon like a literal
demon oh geez okay more more literal
okay and I like met this woman who's
like a like a seer and she's like oh
like you got this like demon inside you
and my curse it's like how did you know
that she's like yeah like it's really
angry and like do you like do you wanna
know more about it because I know some
stuff cuz like I can see the future and
you're like please tell me and then the
demon like took over my body and like I
started attacking her and it's like now
I'm in combat and so I had to they're
like okay the only way to get either I
have to murder this woman or I'm gonna
play this game right now my or I have to
get my character down to a certain
amount of health to like knock me out of
the trance so I had to have all my other
companions like attack me so I have like
all my conveniens like shooting me in
the face with bones it's is such a like
a Dungeons & Dragons ish kind of like
you really start developing a character
like through your abilities and stuff
but also through the choices you're
making that kind of tie into it's so
great at I'm already loving that aspect
of it but it's also very much like this
is another kind of funny thing that
happened that I don't think I told
everybody because it was embarrassing
that whole so there's your you're in a
prison like I think most the gameplay
we're seeing right now you're on this
island it's called fort yeah it's great
name area but you you're essentially
trying to figure out how to get out of
there and then but there's it's such
it's so great at like giving each
character a motivation to get out there
he'll be like I need to go see this
person about regaining my throne cuz I'm
this exiled Prince and then this girl
will be like I need to go I need to find
this area apparently there's this safe
spot and then but also how you're
getting out a lot of the companions will
kind of have or either stumble upon
strategies like I stumbled into this
area by following by playing hide and
seek with this kid and then I came upon
just like 1,000 years yeah that wasn't
your old night with a spear through his
chest that had petrified him but he was
also an undead character so my dialogue
options when I pulled the spear out of
his chest and he came back to life kind
of undead life he's like oh thank you
you're one of my kin and I appreciate it
but then that gave me a way out because
he's like here's a map you can go to
this part of you can sneak in by
pressing this button on this statue in
the courtyard but then there's another
point where going
back to that yeah a lot of many lizards
are seers as the only lizards our seers
now the elf that elf is okay their seers
they can essentially they're kind of
like they're kind of like bran from Game
of Thrones or something you can see
stuff but someone so she killed him
because she had beef with him she just
slid open his stomach I was like oh
great I hope I don't need him and I went
over to talk to someone else and he's
like apparently there's a lizard seer
nearby that could help you get out of
the prison like [ __ ] hanging out around
but is there anyone else
yeah can you are you see her by any
chance okay it's really fun Safari and I
want to play more co-op right yeah we
should start a game co-op is it kind of
changes the way it reminds me of like
playing an actual D&D campaign where
yeah you know you're like okay guys this
is what we need to do but everyone kind
of has their own like objective or what
they want to do so I can split up so um
my brother was playing a skeleton we
couldn't figure out that he needed to
like put like a bucket on his head or
whatever so every time you try to walk
into like the area everyone would
immediately like murder all of us so
we're like okay you need to go hang out
in the wood no and we're gonna go do the
quest and then eventually he's like all
right I got a hood I'll wear that and
all right cool we can come in now
he's the Charlie Kelly I'm Marty okay
yeah why you what's what are you wearing
bushes for here oh that does the stealth
you can stealth so I was stealthy up to
these enemies and then my character gets
extra damage when I'm on a high place so
yeah I'm a ranger and the range and so
high that got up to a high ledge and
then been moved to this barrel over to
where they were in that I shot it to
start the fighting and set that giant
crocodile on fire is it like I mean this
is probably a dumb question but is it
like did you find a detrimental at all
like flying co-op we know no as far as
some of these characters like I can't
stop think about the one you were
describing we're like you literally
weren't able to control your character
because the demon was controlling me
controlling like I'm killing you again
do anybody I thought my fault like co-op
you get into these weird things were
just um you know yeah it's like okay I'm
I'm gonna go do this quest and you're
like yeah I went in like stole a bunch
of [ __ ] and then you can do you get like
mess with people where you can be like
hey man check out this sick sword I I
bought I want you to have it you're like
oh thanks and it's like totally stolen
and then like our guard will come on to
be like oh you stole that I'm gonna put
you in prison now and then you're in
prison but he's fine or you can take a
health potion or you can a poison potion
dye it red and it looks like a health
potion you can give it to your buddies
you be like hey man here come over here
have a potion or conversely maybe dye
some potion green and give it to an on
get guess what I imagine 2/3 agree like
you the game you could just spend hours
just like messing with your friends well
just I feel like there's so many
opportunities to like really roll a 1 on
any encounter just just like totally
mess it up right and screw up and then
you have to roll with it like the idea
of like oh I just wait til every my
friends can lower my health so the demon
escapes me just like or yeah it's like
I'm I was talking with that guy and
having a very nice conversation and then
my friend just goes I've been throw a
shell of this face yeah I mean a spirit
it's hard to say like I would encourage
everyone if you if you're into like RPGs
absolutely play this game it's
definitely you have a PC place game and
I know like the game players seeing it
is very very dense to say the least
menu wise possibility wise emergent
gameplay wise but you should definitely
try to play I I can't remember the last
time I played a game where I was less
prone to like reloading a save I'm like
I'm gonna roll with this choice I'm if
this is this will make it interesting
somehow she killed our only way out of
prison so maybe I'll just be here for
another 20 hours and I'll still find
[ __ ] to do no I will say you'll probably
have a little better time if you play it
single-player in terms of just like
traditional video game like you know you
can read all the dialogue and kind of
have you know options with quests like
when you're playing co-op everyone has
conversations separately and you can
listen in but you could also like
completely miss a conversation because
your friend like went off and talked to
another person and you don't know what
that conversation was so there's a
reliance I like talking with them or
when like he talked to this person
activate this quest if I go talk to them
they don't know who I am so like it's
like oh you have to talk to this person
now because you have that built-in
relationship with that character so that
can get like I like that I know it's
cool but it can get kind of hard to
manage and like we hit a point where
like say yelling at Ben Jay just was
like okay what should we do and we're
all like why of this quest and it's like
why have these three quests and we just
like had no idea what to do and like
it's it's a game that is so dense that
you can get lost and it just becomes
even harder when you have a bunch of
people want to do stuff but so if you
have to kind of like let go the fact
that like maybe you're not gonna get
that much accomplished if you're playing
by yourself but the room on the reverse
end like the satisfaction of playing
with people and like that role-playing
experience is like really really cool
yeah I would definitely say you'll
understand the systems and mechanics
that play better if you maybe play like
8 to 10 hours of single-player and
that's really nothing in this game
although you certainly learn stuff
together like that's how we were like oh
guys I found out that you know poison
hurts me and it's a healing hurts me
like someone cool I mean like the team
both like many people played a lot of
breath of the while it reminds me
nothing at all like breath of the wild
but in the sense that there's a ton to
do but somehow they make it so it's not
overwhelming so you don't mind that
you're missing out on a lot of stuff
because you're still doing a bunch of
these cool things that other people
probably didn't see yeah yeah I think
the best way to design something like
that is to just make it like I just
follow what you think is interesting
yeah and then you're not missing out
totally story's yours and the writing is
fantastic I'm not just saying that
because really really helps it's funny
like as hell at some parts especially
seeing all this stuff like kind of
interact my character is I'm a polymorph
so I can turn into like the like
specialize in two-handed weapons right
now but you can turn into like a astral
a spectral Bowl with horns and then ram
people or turn your arm into like an
octopus tentacle that stuns people it's
really fun so far yeah it's like so much
stuff like that hell elves in this game
can eat body parts to like relive
memories there's crocodiles like we
found a corpse later buying like like
our health character ate
and we just uh sorry notice I sang it
wrong no I said crocodile and it's just
like the last moments of this guy who
got like eaten by a crocodile and like
him being like that and thing could go
out this way huh like ooh-ahh cow but
then you actually can get like cool you
can like learn like how to do something
like oh we killed that guy but I eat him
and oh I gained the information that he
had and we can solve it that way and
then later you meet a guy with one arm
he's like hey if you see my arm anywhere
and you're like yeah I actually like a
bunch of like severed heads in my like I
have just like hey let's just have my
elfia you see what we've learned my ELF
eat it
hey come check out my heads yep I have I
have a few separate lemons my backpack
right now so uh co-op wise its four
player co-op up to four up to four and
that's it it's anything like down the
road this game seems like it's like no
sir there's an arena mode for a PvP
stuff yet is that out yeah yes that is I
believe that's out and there's also that
Dungeons & Dragons mode that we did a
while before that's yeah was kind of
looting - that thing was really neat
today so that's in the game that's crazy
essentially you can make your own custom
like campaign oh cool assisted DMing so
you have one you have everyone played
the party and then you have a fifth
person played the DM and yeah you can
create the map ahead of time and they
can also at any point pause the game and
then like change things around they can
type in dialog like they can completely
control it and they actually have a
really good like tutorial area they play
which is one of like the D&D like
starter quests as like an example of
like here's how to do it oh that's
totally real rad there's such like you
can create your own campaigns and the
game also has really good mod support
for just all sorts of things but you can
download other people's like campaigns
and play them and then like DM it
yourself
dammit yes so it was surprisingly
familias as someone who doesn't know D&D
though that well at all it was
surprisingly engaging and entertaining
to watch well it was Justin John Luke
and Michael hi I'm late and Justin was
this like what was his character his
background was like yeah
oh yeah literally dm's and really he's
doing this role-playing oh hello good
sir he went up to this like it was like
some goblin in a cave all the 20 old 20
and like the and the the DM from
divinity was just like oh my God he's
like it was so I woke up today praying
for this [ __ ] basically it was like oh
you're so pretty and it was mesmerized
by Justin and like the Goblin led him
through the cave that's all these
enemies to the end where they met like
the goblin king every whatever it was
and the guy was like I don't know what
Justin says like that he knows you guys
and he's like I don't know this guy like
good looks one more time it was so funny
the dungeons dragons has always had a
one-up or for video games and that
there's like unlimited amount of options
you can do right yeah yeah yeah and the
single player in this game feels like
they're trying to push it to its
absolute limits where it has almost at
like breath of the wild like oh can I
try that like oh wow that actually does
look like they thought of so many things
but it still is at the end of the day a
video game that is limited that DM mode
is like just completely it gives you the
tools to do what totally breaks it open
yeah and then you have like this visual
element that you can play with it's
really really cool I've not seen many
limitations yet at all like eight hours
yeah yeah just the single player alone
it's insane what they can offer its on
PC yes so the first one came on Xbox one
I think maximum games ported it about a
year after there's no word on that yet
yeah there's a tweet about that someone
was asking about yeah we have a question
we'll bring up right now Richard you
mind bringing it up apologize I'm
butchering the same.i Turek ROM Johnny
on Twitter was saying any idea about the
release date of divinity original sin 2
on consoles the first of any original
sin Enhanced Edition worked really great
on ps4 oh I don't know when it's coming
out but when they put out the enhanced
edition
they addition to adding a bunch of stuff
they put out like controller support
which was actually like and it changes
all the menus and it works really well
and it also had like split screen so you
do like couch co-op which is really
really fun that stuff is with this game
with this game that sounds pretty
intensive as far as like what your HUD
would look like well simplify know you
could set it you could say like oh we
can it'll be one screen that we shared
or it would like split it or you could
send some would like dynamically split
you just lose some HUD elements or some
like you said yeah yeah it was pretty
well done and this game has it built in
by default I got to have some footage of
me just like with the controller support
like they have it built into the PC
version from get-go so it's a possible
port for sure I think they're definitely
gonna do it I don't know when but I
imagine it will not be as long as the
first game because they already have
that mechanic like like yeah here here's
the controller support it's like they
changes the menus but it's very like
intuitive and easy to do yeah this game
was in early access for the majority of
2017 it wasn't the full game it was a
big chunk of it but now it's out on pc
$60 full price from Larian studios over
in belgium congratulations to them they
made a game that has me hooked and I am
looking forward to playing it more and
yeah like I want to play it right now
it's ready to go
it's fantastic dance yeah won't be
skeleton oh it's it's fun cuz yeah
between the poison and the way people
react to you and like a character's keep
saying like one of your my dialogue
options is undead cuz you do tags right
character tag so I picked like I'm an
outlaw I'm an undead like race but I'm
also my class combat classes the poly
more for a meta more poly more if I
think and like you'll have different
obviously dialogue happens if there's
nothing new but it's funny my undead one
is almost always tell them that your
undead found a better helmet so just
like what they decide to join my quest
like did you have to convince them some
characters easier than others should I
tell them that I'm just a skeleton
real-world application of that just like
hearing it and being like your wife and
their and they're like reviled they're
kind of like the there there's very like
much prejudice against undead characters
in this world I think so this is an item
you can get where you can um any corpse
you can like steal their face back where
it is well any change your race to which
like because of the game actually does
have like race politics like people in
certain quests like will treat you
differently because they're like elves
or something and so it's like oh this
guy only talks to lizards let me go find
a lizard kill them and steal his face
and then I'll go talk to this person and
they'll be more friendly with me see
that seems like the only option yeah
yeah Kali your skin is hanging off your
bones another so one of the characters
she was what's her name
it's the elf that we just saw with this
garter cheek and she like in the
dialogue after you she apparently has
this needle like you ever see kiss of
the dragon with a Jet Li and who else is
in that there's a few people but he the
kiss the dragon is this one spot on the
back of his neck where he put a needle
and you just paralyze and bleed
everywhere so she essentially has his
needle she puts in people to like stun
them and it's like she's pressing
against it she's like she's like one
more inch and I could kill you and I'm
the most painful way possible and then
meanwhile and it's like I convinced her
to join my question very like like
untrust distrusting of me and uh and
then after that I was like by the way
I'm undead she's like yeah I know I
didn't feel skin at all when I was
presently I'm not an idiot so much
dialogue yeah yeah that's like half the
brilliance this game I can't imagine how
many words of dialogue they had to write
for every possible situation it seems
like astronomical I can't imagine other
game to compare a million words apparent
like compared it like if you compare
Skyrim to this it must be like it must
dwarf Skyrim it's insane
[Music]